hey everybody what's going on blade here
I'm here with Freddie Prinze jr. and
Cameron what's your lesson to me Cameron
what kemberly Cameron Lee and today
we're playing Dragon Age Inquisition
look at this bad boy right here it comes
out in the 18th in North America right
and then the rest of the world one sorry
so North Americans the 22 November
awesome great so uh yeah I think and
Freddie has you are a voice in the game
that's right I'm the iron bull the iron
bull and we're gonna play you you love
this you can play this game yeah I just
were literally like one mission past
where I'm at Cameron made it Manor
Inquisitor Conan and pretty what were
you saying about you know gonna play
girl character why yeah well this is why
cuz now for the next hour and a half you
can see it dudes a part of it yeah so
let's Sandra wolf romance my characters
you can go both ways that's right let's
kill us to kill a giant flying lizard
alright which one do you want to do that
the desert one it is it was awesome yeah
that's awesome and you you ready you
took your timing shirt oh my god yeah
I'm like met someone on Twitter who's
like my my twin sister they're like
every joke I made my cape her name's
tech wizard early Oh perfect fan of
Dragon Age she is so shoutout
do you right now but uh I was literally
tweeted this the other night like it was
almost midnight and I was just like I
said exploring and turned this random
corner through this cave and came out
the other and I saw these baby dragons
and I was like oh my god that's babies
right we walked up to the mama dragon
and launches this fireball and we I ran
my veterans except the room
I was in the north of course was the
first time
three features give it help Freddy Oh
[Music]
[Music]
be against entire business
what's all that
what was that
[Music]
try out the desert
oh this was the fire dress
man
oh please everyone is different
why
bounine a movie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
resistant tape it easy to competitor
five
do the spell interaction
[Music]
the screener game the firewall that's
kaarvok for these other these people are
not on camera I feel like they're
handing out your baby and nervous you
have
yeah but you guys probably do not like
well we're done see now that's how you
react to killing a drag yeah I think
where's the loot they have the Dragons
skull right yeah
what's me then I've show the looter yeah
we got the nameless blade silver Dragon
Age November 18th baby yeah
you